be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so picking up with flashpoint part two
we initially start with Slade Wilson
with Deathstroke now this is a very
interesting set of circumstances because
we would expect to see Deathstroke
assassinating people or something along
those lines but instead
Deathstroke's actually a pirate now to
be honest here I really like what Geoff
Johns did with Deathstroke I really like
the idea of Deathstroke being a pirate
somehow it just fits I mean not
necessarily because Deathstroke is is
cold-hearted but because in a lot of
ways Deathstroke is just a loner but
he's also kind of a guy you don't mess
with and you could easily see him you
know being a modern-day pirate which
again I think works perfectly but what
we also know is that because they're
pirates they're basically just searching
the world over for Salvage they're just
looking for they're just trying to live
essentially there's taken a day by day
and what they're doing is they're using
the powers of a character named sonar
now the sonar is is actually interesting
this is why I think Geoff Johns did a
great job with flash point because sonar
was a minor villain at best you know he
was largely a Green Lantern villain and
he had the ability to manipulate sound
but instead of him being a guy that just
kind of lays waste to things and
fighting alongside or maybe even being a
hero instead he's just being used as an
object here he's basically serving as a
way for Slade Wilson to scan underwater
and see if there's anything worth
getting now this is effectively torture
for sonar just because of the fact that
in order for him to use his powers
effectively or to be forced to use his
powers effectively he's being
electrocuted by another character named
electric eel and so again this is just
showing us how ruthless and how harsh
life is in this flashpoint society and
that individuals characters are just
kind of being torn to pieces and just
being forced to live miserable lives but
during their during their scouting
mission they come across another ship
and when they see it's flag they realize
it belongs to a character named warlord
the problem here is that the ship and
everybody on it has been absolutely
massacred and this is this is shown to
us by the fact that Europe seems to have
been entirely flooded now this is why we
have you know Slade Wilson running
around as a pirate but we also learned
that his ship has been set upon by
Aquaman now this is where things get a
little crazy here this is where things
get a little weird initially we were
just kind of left to our own devices to
figure things out but with Aquaman being
so ruthless
we actually switched back to Gotham City
with Barry Allen
Thomas Wayne now again for those are
guys who were just getting caught up
with those you guys you saw the last
video this part of the video where this
part of our discussion takes place prior
to the adventure between you know the
main flashpoint story in the last video
and our segment on what happened to
Bruce Wayne and so this kind of fills in
the gaps for those of you guys who were
waiting for this bit of information to
come around because Barry Allen realizes
that this is Thomas Wayne he kind of
he's kind of shocked here a Thomas Wayne
again doesn't know who barry allen is
from his perspective this is just a
random guy who showed up who discovered
his location in the Batcave and he
doesn't know what his intentions are but
barry is actually able to talk sense in
a thomas wayne even if thomas is only a
little bit skeptical here but what also
happens is Barry's mind is kind of being
fractured in the sense that his memories
of the way things used to be and his
memories of the way things are now
are starting to converge in the sense
that he's losing his former self what
we're told is that at some point along
the line Wonder Woman and Aquaman had
basically engaged in war with one
another that Wonder Woman had led a
blitzkrieg in tearing London to pieces
and that Aquaman had flooded the
entirety of Europe now there is a tie-in
that explains what happened here there
is an explanation on what it is it took
place it kind of provides the backstory
here which again you know I'm all for
going over if you guys are interested or
if you guys just kind of want to stick
with the main story for what it is it's
fine by me but because of the fact that
Barry is starting to experience you know
this emergence of memories what geoff
johns is basically done here is he's
given us a time frame he's basically
said that if things don't go back to
normal after a certain amount of time
Barry Allen will lose everything that
makes him who he is and he'll basically
be stuck in this timeline remembering
how things are as opposed to the way
things should be and so during this bit
of recall so to speak his ring fogs out
falls out of his pocket now again this
is what Barry Allen houses his uniform
at you know whenever it is these on the
run whenever he's on the move he always
has his ring there so we could pop it
out for easy access do whatever it is
nice do and then go back to being his
normal self and this is what he tells
Thomas Wayne he says that he has the
ring whenever he needs to be a superhero
and he'll prove to Thomas Wayne that
he's the flash even if he doesn't have
his powers he'll prove to Thomas Wayne
who he is by virtue of showing him his
flash costume but when he uses the ring
and when he brings his costume out is
actually the costume of reverse-flash
eobard thawne and Barry Allen
immediately comes to the belief comes to
the conclusion that eobard thawne has
somehow
screw with time now this is interesting
here because as far as we know eobard
thawne was trapped in the speedforce you
know during the end of flash rebirth we
don't we don't have any reason to
believe that eobard thawne is involved
here but because of the fact that the
Speed Force is outside of space and time
a person who's there could access any
point in time this is compounded by the
fact that eobard thawne has the ability
to manipulate time which is why he was
able to go back through and screw up the
life of barry allen leading him to
become the flash in the first place all
of which of course was covered in my
last video in the end Barry Allen
basically makes the case that this is
all eobard thawne's doing that eobard
thawne had somehow gone to the Past and
changed things and because things have
been changed barry allen basically sees
himself as the one person that could
make things the way that they're
supposed to be now of course he gives
Thomas Wayne a bit of his backstory he
gives how explain explanation that
eobard thawne was lived in the 25th
century became obsessed with barry allen
travelled into the past realized that he
was going to be a bad guy which broke
his sanity and then went further into
the past and began engineering the
circumstances of Barry Allen's life that
led him to becoming the flash including
switching chemicals around so that when
Barry Allen was struck by lightning he
would become the flash on killing Barry
Allen's mother Nora Allen forcing Barry
Allen's family to move all the things
that led up to that particular moment
we're all done by eobard thawne and so
Barry Allen makes the case that in order
for things to go back to normal in order
for Bruce Wayne to live and Thomas Wayne
to die that that Thomas basically has to
help Barry Allen get his speed back he
has to help him become the flash again
and so what we do is we switch over to
London which has now been christened as
new Themis Kira under the control of
Wonder Woman and we see a soldier who we
don't initially know who he is going
through and trying to keep himself alive
against the forces of the Amazons trying
to try to keep from dying to be quite
frank but in the middle of this conflict
he's a mission he's eventually captured
and taken prisoner by Wonder Woman who
uses her lasso of truth now again the
lasso of truth basically forces those
who use the lasso er who when snared in
the lasso to tell the truth and it does
have its weaknesses which we can get
into at a later day once we get closer
to the Wonder Woman movie but the lasso
of truth is used on this soldier who
reveals himself to be Steve Trevor now
again this is just Geoff Johns showing
us another instance of how things have
changed because Steve Trevor was
basically Wonder Woman's liaison to the
world of humans when she first arrived
but more so than that
was her first major love interest among
normal society and so to see them as
bitter enemies is a huge difference it
tells us that most likely Wonder Woman
never left Amazon are never left amiss
here in the first place even if she did
things didn't turn out quite the same
way now we're not told if Steve Trevor
played a role in that but I would
surmise that because Steve Trevor was
Wonder Woman's way of segwaying in a
normal society because he showed her so
many different things because he showed
her how to conduct herself as a normal
person he was basically able to make her
human you know to take her away from
this this life that she had previously
led and allowed her to become a stronger
character because now she was able to
balance her life emptiness Keira as well
as her life as a regular superhero which
eventually in the new 52 gave way to a
romance with Superman himself but we
also learned is that Steve Trevor is
here for the purpose of rescuing Lois
Lane now the reason for this is that
Lois Lane is one of the greatest
journalists in the world at the moment
and she had basically gone undercover
into London to gather as much
information as possible for cyborg who's
working on behalf of the US government
in order to allow him to organize an
attack and to basically subvert the
forces of Wonder Woman now assuming that
you may have noticed here is something
you may be scratching your head about is
if Lois Lane is in London and she is in
danger
why hasn't Superman rescued her yet and
we will actually get to that later on in
this story but instead we switch back to
Gotham City and this is basically kind
of like a Jimmy rigged experiment what's
happening here is a very Alan and Thomas
way and have rigged a really an
execution you know an electrocution
chair in order to put Barry Allen in
this situation where he'll be doused in
the same chemicals that he was when he
first got his powers and then he'll be
struck by lightning during a rainstorm
and he'll become the flash again at
least that's their hope the problem with
this is that when this happens when this
lightning strike takes place and when
Barry Allen is hit by lightning he
doesn't become the flash instead he's
just covered in scars
he is absolutely fried and so it seems
as though there's no way for Barry Allen
to become the flash again at least
that's the information that's given to
us at the conclusion of this second
issue by Jeff Jones but what happens ed
if you guys are enjoying this so far
drop a like hit the sub button become
part of the robb core and leave a
comment I gotta tell you guys flash
one of the best stories that I've read
in a long time because for me you know
as a kind of book fan there's nothing I
love more than seeing alternate
realities where things just go really
bad and I don't mean to sound cynical I
don't mean to make it sound like I'm a
terrible person but I think we all like
it I think we all like to see what
happens with superheroes go bad or when
the world just descends into chaos
we love dystopian stuff if you guys love
dystopian stuff like post a comment tell
me tell me why does it you love
flashpoint so much is it because it's
just a different take on characters or
is it because things are just really
really bad it here that's my reason I
just love seeing things really really
bad but anyway we're gonna bring this
video to an end hopefully you guys
enjoyed it if you did let me know and I
will catch you guys later peace
[Music]